salut les rêves lucides ça fascine le
sommeil ça fascine depuis 2016 je vous
ai fait pas mal de vidéos sur le sujet à
chaque fois que je vous ai parlé des
trucs très cool qu'on peut faire avec
son sommeil et aujourd'hui on va parler
justement des choses un petit peu moins
cool qui surviennent comme ça le
syndrome de la tête qui expose la
paralysie du sommeil le somnambulisme
même un mec qui a tué quelqu'un en
pleine crise de somnambulisme lui aussi
comprendre des choses sur un peu moins
grave genre pourquoi on parle en dormant
pourquoi y en a qui ont des orgasmes en
dormant alors c'est parti générique
vous voyez je suis pas dans mon décor
habituel là je suis dans les anciens
bureaux où je fais les live
habituellement c'est simplement parce
que loïc a été testé positif aux que
vides
et denis aussi
heureusement en étant télétravail donc
nous on n'était pas là il reste plus
grand monde au bureau pour tout vous
dire je sais même pas qui dans l'équipe
va monter la vidéo ça sauf que c'est moi
nope reprenons depuis le début salut les
rêves lucides ça fascine le sommeil ça
fascine depuis 2016 je vous ai fait pas
mal de vidéos sur le sujet mido remonte
au sein
de la journée on dort et pendant qu'on
dort le cerveau se met en mode par
défaut ce qui fait qu'aider petit michel
qui viennent là haut aux manettes
utiliser le cerveau pendant qu'on en a
pas conscience ces petits michel on peut
leur donner des indications pour faire
ce qu'on appelle des rêves lucides à
savoir faire un rêve où l'on a
conscience que l'on rêve à partir de là
deux possibilités soit celle de
contrôler à 100% son rêve le décor les
personnages etc soit celle de contrôle
est juste les actions qu'on fait dans
notre rêve mais dans un décor imposer un
peu comme si on nous re télécharger à
l'intérieur d'un film on peut pas
changer le film en lui-même mais on fait
ce qu'on veut à l'intérieur si les rêves
lucides ça vous intéresse je vous
mettrai des liens dans la description de
vidéos bien plus complète que j'ai fait
à ce sujet et si le fait de savoir
comment marche d'autres cerveau à l'aide
des petits michel qui est dedans sachez
que je peux pas mal de tik tok sur le
sujet je vous mets également un lien
dans la description avant de vous parler
de trucs chelous et anecdotes marrantes
comme le syndrome de la tête qui expose
on va peut-être reprendre par la base de
ces kwal sommeil si ça vous intéresse
pas ou que vous connaissez ça par coeur
je vous mets un petit chapitre âge vous
êtes juste à cliquer pour passer
directement au premier sans groen
votre sommeil est composé en gros de 3 à
6 cycles différents quand vous allez
vous coucher vous allez faire une
transition entre l'état de veille et
l'état de sommeil et c'est un état très
léger parce que quand vous vous endormez
vous êtes encore connecté à votre
environnement dit à vos cinq sens vous
entendez encore les bruits ou les
percevez vous les comprenez ensuite vous
rentrez dans la phase de sommeil lent
léger c'est une phase où là vous
commencez à - percevoir des bruits ou
les conscientiser - ne vous pouvez vous
réveiller très facilement là vous
arrivez dans le sommeil lent profond ou
là bas vous réagissez quasiment pas ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur sauf si
quelqu'un arrive avec une trompette
évidemment mais sinon s'il ya des petits
bruits qui ne sont pas inhabituelles
votre cerveau michel là-haut chez un des
liens avec les michel du cerveau
lancement les michel la houle comprendre
le bruit vont dire ok ça en connaît on
le réveille pas et là enfin vous rentrez
dans le sommeil paradoxal c'est un
sommeil très profond ou même aux
constantes elle change la respiration
change les battements du coeur change
tout et au ralenti et en général c'est
là où vous vous mettez à rêver et
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps c'est
parce qu'on se réveille en pleine phase
de sommeil paradoxal qu'on se souvient
encore de son rêve au réveil avant
qu'ils soient évacués combien de temps
ça dure un cycle de sommeil baffe n'y a
pas vraiment de règle il ya un consensus
qui dit qu'en moyenne ces 90 minutes et
puisqu'on va aborder les trucs chelous
qui sont pas très agréables conflit
pendant le sommeil sachez qu'une
personne sur trois est atteinte de
parasomnie c'est à dire que le cycle du
sommeil est perturbé par du stress de
l'anxiété ce genre de choses
on commence avec quelque chose que 30%
de la population a déjà vécu c'est la
paralysie du sommeil si vous l'avez pas
vécu vous pouvez pas vraiment comprendre
ce que c'est tellement c'est bizarre à
ressentir comme son nom l'indiqué la
paralysie du sommeil c'est une vraie
paralysie complète ça se passe pendant
la phase d'endormissement ou durant la
phase de réveil à ce moment précis tous
vos muscles sont paralysés sauf le
muscle des globes oculaires donc vous
pouvez bouger les yeux et les muscles
respiratoires donc à part respirer et
bouger les yeux vous pouvez rien faire
mais ce qui est terrible c'est que vous
êtes conscience alors c'est un problème
qui est pas très grave qu'est ce qui se
passe durant le sommeil paradoxal et
bien votre cerveau coupe l'accès à tous
les muscles tous les muscles sont
paralysés pour éviter que vous bougiez
en fonction du rêve que vous êtes en
train de faire c'est en train de battre
c'est avec que tu sois en train de
battre par exemple et donc la paralysie
du sommeil c'est un défaut en fait dans
le cerveau ou un moment précis tu as
conscience se réveille avant qu'on
réactive les muscles alors que par mal
les deux sont réactives en même temps
donc il ya un petit délire entre les
deux et toi pas dans ce télé ben tu dis
waouh qu'est ce qui se passe mais comme
si ça ne suffisait pas il ya une steppe
là dessus dans le côté un peu horrifique
c'est que parfois la paralysie est
associé à des hallucinations auditives
ou visuel on ressent du froid on voit
des ombres chelou on entend des
craquements ou des bruits qui n'existe
pas limite on peut aussi voir des choses
là clairement tu te fais ton film
d'horreur alors c'est bien fabien
d'identifier ça mais comment on s'en
sort et bien en général confie une
paralysie du sommeil on a tendance à
paniquer mentalement à respirer de plus
en plus vides avoir le coeur qui
s'emballe parce que ça fait peur
maintenant que vous connaissez ça sachez
que ça dure quelques secondes et au pire
quelques minutes s'il y en a qui en ont
fait vous pouvez témoigner dans les
commentaires de combien de temps ça vous
appris comment vous en êtes sortis le
truc est paradoxal c'est que pour sortir
d'une paralysie du sommeil il faut au
contraire rester très calme respirez
lentement et là ça va débloquer de
l'ensemble encore plus rapidement que si
on attendait que ça se passe
naturellement peuvent vous reprenez le
contrôle
alors dis comme ça le syndrome de la
tête qui expose sa part est un truc très
flippant est très grave c'est comme la
paralysie du sommeil c'est très
dérangeant mais c'est pas si grave que
ça et peut-être vous l'avez déjà vécu et
vous ne savez même pas que c'était un
syndrome ce qui se passe avec ce
syndrome c'est que vous vous réveiller
en pleine nuit comme s'ils avaient eu
une explosion un bruit énorme grosse
porte qui claque à côté de vous ou
quelqu'un qui vient de crier à un truc
genre comme ça très fort ça ça vous
parle ça mais tu te réveilles tu peux
vous qu'est ce qui s'est passé est en
fait il s'est rien passé les causes de
ce syndrome sont pas vraiment connus
aujourd'hui il ya plein de médecins qui
s'interroge ya pas vraiment de consensus
on pense que ce serait peut-être un
problème d'oreille interne en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est que si vous
avez ce syndrome très régulièrement
genre plusieurs fois par semaine même
une fois par semaine mais toutes les
semaines n'hésitez pas à les consulter
un médecin n'empêche que quand c'est
parce que c'est ça peut avoir des
conséquences je vous raconte une
anecdote qui a été racontée par isabelle
arnulf neurologue et directrice des
unités de pathologies du sommeil à la
pitié salpêtrière où il ya quelques
années à la rencontrer un homme qui tous
les soirs entendez les portes clic est
très fort en fait ce qu il entendait
précisément pour reprendre ses mots
c'était une sorte d'explosion et à
chaque fois ça le réveiller salle sous
les dons qu'il a commencé à faire des
mots qu'il a affichée sur l'ascenseur et
sur les portes de son immeuble en disant
aux voisins de se calmer un petit peu le
soir mais rien n'a changé donc ils
allaient s'embrouiller vraiment avec
tous ses voisins ça n'a rien calmé du
tout du coup il s'est barré pour vivre à
la campagne et ça continue et c'est là
qu'il s'est dit il ya peut-être un souci
c'est peut-être dans ma tête à moi du
coup c'est pour ça que je trouvais ça
sympa d'en parler parce que peut-être
vous l'avez déjà expérimenté sans même
le savoir moi je suis sortie de rêve
lucide pour le coup avec ce genre
d'explosion là que j'ai eu vraiment
l'impression d'entendre dans la vraie
vie maintenant on va parler d'un autre
trouble que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
déjà vécu c'est le somnambulisme alors
il ya divers dose de somnambulisme on va
voir ça
pourquoi je disais que beaucoup d'entre
vous ont déjà expérimenté le
somnambulisme parce que ça touche un
enfant sur quatre et après en général ça
disparaît à l'âge adulte et c'est l'un
des rares troubles qui a lieu dans le
sommeil profond et les dernières études
ont montré que c'est principalement les
garçons de ce qu'en réalité il ya une
réelle prédisposition génétique des
chercheurs du centre avancé des études
du sommeil du sacré-coeur ont mis en
avant qu'un enfant à trois à sept fois
plus de chance ou de risque plutôt de
faire du somnambulisme si ses parents
faisait eux aussi du somnambulisme ou
des terreurs nocturnes
alors quand on pense au somnambulisme on
a toujours à peu près la même vision
quelqu'un debout les yeux ouverts les
bras tendus comme ça qui marche en
faisant des trucs chelous etc en réalité
c'est plus simple que ça en général le
somnambule a les yeux ouverts oui ils
regardent plutôt dans le vide il bouge
pas beaucoup généralement il va faire
des actions très simple du style
s'asseoir sur le bord du lit par exemple
ou marcher un petit peu mais c'est
rarement plus forcément si je dis serra
en plus c'est que dans leurs armes en
plus leila ya des trucs chelous on a vu
des somnambules faire à manger et faire
de la cuisine écrire des mails conduire
leur voiture là ça devient un petit peu
dangereux quand même et comprenez bien
qu'à son réveil le somnambule ne se
souviendra à jamais de rien de quoi que
ce soit il n'aura même pas eu conscience
d'avoir fait une crise de somnambulisme
et dites-moi est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu cette fameuse phrase il ne faut
pas réveiller un somnambule alors y'a
rien dangereux a réveillé un somnambule
les seules deux choses que vous pouvez
provoquer à la personne qui était en
crise de somnambulisme seyssois bas de
la mauvaise humeur parce que c'est pas
assez par où vous de se faire réveiller
quand on dort soit de l' angoisse parce
que peut-être à personnel de boue avait
se demander ce qui se passe etc il n'y a
pas une vraie dangerosité la vraie bonne
solution c'est que si vous avez
quelqu'un qui est somnambule dans votre
entourage etc élevé en dehors du lit
vous le prenez vous le raccompagner vous
pouvez parler doucement mais juste de le
guider en fait en lui prenant la main ça
suffit la personne se recouche mais
alors du coup si on peut se déplacer
parfois ou faire des tâches complexes
que me faire à manger ou écrit un mail
est ce que on peut faire des actes
graves suzy pnns
et bien vous dis c'est pas que dans les
films c'est arrivé le 24 mai 1997
kenneth parks prend sa voiture il roule
pendant une vingtaine de kilomètres
garé la voiture et rentrer dans la
maison de ses beaux-parents pendant
qu'ils dorment de là il va étrangler son
beau père eelv a poignardé sa belle-mère
qui va succomber à ses blessures et
qu'est ce qu'il a fait après il est
remonté dans sa voiture il est allé au
poste de police le plus proche pour dire
qu'ils venaient d'étrangler son
beau-père et de poignarder sa belle-mère
il ya une vraie question qui se pose en
donnant aux logis puisqu'au moment de
l'acte il était en train de dormir en
pleine crise de somnambulisme donc sans
aucune intention et sans sans aucune
connaissance de ce qu'ils faisaient et
qui s'en souvient pas au réveil est ce
qu'il est vraiment responsable de ses
actes et bien dans ce cas précis il n'a
pas été condamné parce que justement il
a été reconnu qu'il était somnambule qui
faisait des crises de somnambulisme
quasiment chaque nuit et que lui même
n'en avait pas conscience alors comment
on peut venir à bout du somnambulisme
quand on est dans un cas comme nuit qui
est quand même extrêmement rare et bien
l'hypnose thérapeutique est une même
pratique par exemple si vous l'avez pas
vu j'ai fait une vidéo sur l'hypnose si
j'y pense la mettrais dans la
description sinon metella vous même
description dans les commentaires il ya
eu un autre cas de meurtres sous hypnose
c'est le cas de scott fondateur il a
assassiné sa femme en la poignardant
dans un premier temps et ensuite en la
noyant dans une piscine sa soeur la
soeur du meurtrier à a confirmé qu'il
faisait de grosses crises de
somnambulisme qui lui donnait toujours
un petit aspect démoniaque et pourtant
il n'a pas été acquittée il a il a dû
payer pour son crime pourquoi et bien
parce que les enquêteurs ont découvert
qu'il avait caché les vêtements et
l'arme du crime qu'il avait nettoyé le
sang sur ses propres vêtements et qui
s'était changé qu'il avait essayé
d'effacer ses traces sur l'armé du crime
ça fait énormément d'action en fait et
surtout ces actions n'ont pas été faites
dans la foulée donc ça veut dire que sa
crise aurait dû durer des heures des
heures et des heures ou alors par
à-coups qu'il aurait repris sa crise
pour re venir compléter des tâches
complexes qu'il avait commencé c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on connaît dans le
somnambulisme et ça montre qu'il y avait
eu sûrement préméditation en tout cas
pour le procureur scott était bien
conscient et d'après lui il a utilisée
comme excuse ce trouble la du sommeil
pour essayer de couvrir un peu son crime
bon on va revenir cirdi plus fun sur
pourquoi on pas dormans et on terminera
sur pourquoi on a des orgasmes en
dormant ou qu'est ce qui s'passe
par les endormant on appelle ça la somme
ni logos qui peut-être que vous avez
déjà parlé en dormant peut-être que vous
avez quelqu'un dans votre vie qui parle
en dormant énormément c'est toujours
très très drôle faut savoir que 66% des
personnes qui disent avoir déjà parlé en
dormant mais ya que 6% de la population
qui parlent régulièrement lors de leur
phase ii sommes d'ailleurs quand on dit
que quelqu'un parlant de moi c'est pas
forcément tenir une conversation on
s'appelle juste un mot mais quelques
syllabes un peu inaudible c'est pas
forcément par les boucles isabelle
arnulf dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure a mené une étude sur 232
patients atteints de somnambulisme et de
troubles du sommeil pour essayer de
mieux comprendre la semaine d'août
pendant que volontaire dormait des
micros étaient penchés enregistré tous
mes sous sur tous les sons enregistrés
883 pour être précis la plupart d'entre
eux c'était des rires des chuchotements
et des grognements c'était seulement
moins de la moitié des sont 41% qui
correspondaient à des mots ou à des
phrases entières l'un duvet et frédéric
bureau qui est linguistique sont
analysés cesson et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant déjà la majorité des
participants ont plutôt prononcé des
phrases négative ou à connotation
négative 21% des phrases et des mots
entendus c'était non non non non non non
ne fait pas ça ne fait pas ça fait
toujours violent et négatifs les hommes
parlerait plus souvent que les femmes
selon cette étude no 26 hommes pour 16
femmes est toujours dans la même étude
ces hommes-là été particulièrement
grossier et puis si vous êtes un bavard
une bavarde de nocturnia pas vraiment de
choses à faire en réalité il n'ya pas de
traitement particulier ou pensent encore
une fois que c'est lié au stress donc un
petit massage en dormir et y ait un gros
dodo alors là on va pas vraiment parler
d'un trouble mais de quelque chose qui
se produit quand même pour 80% des
femmes et 40 % des hommes au moins une
fois dans leur vie
beaucoup d'hommes ont déjà eu des
érections associé à une sensation
d'excitation en réveil en ayant
conscience de pourquoi il était excité
de quoi ils venaient de rêver pour les
femmes c'est moins visible
nécessairement donc elles peuvent
parfois se réveiller sans avoir eu le
souvenir d'avoir une excitation sexuelle
ou un orgasme mais comment ça peut se
produire pour les hommes et pour les
femmes d'aller jusqu'à l'orgasme alors
qu'il ya pas eu de contact physique et
bien déjà apparemment le fait de dormir
sur le ventre ça favoriserait ça
[Musique]
on le sait depuis longtemps et il ya une
étude en 1992 qui a confirmé que les
femmes arrivées aussi avoir un orgasme
uniquement par la pensée
d'où le fait aussi par la méditation
tantrique ce genre de choses c'est tout
à fait possible alors si en plus c'est
associé à une position propice durant le
sommeil et à des petits rêves qui aident
et oui alors pour certains génies
colonnes ce serait une manière 80 le
cerveau d'évacuer un peu les tensions et
le stress de la journée pourquoi pas et
pour d'autres ce serait au contraire
purement physiologique à ce serait une
manière pour les corps caverneux de se
ré oxygéner un type bon en tout les cas
c'est pas la chose la plus désagréable
qui puisse nous arriver durant le
sommeil je voulais dit au tout début de
cette vidéo ce tournage il n'était pas
prévu comme ça aujourd'hui je vais vous
dire ce qui était prévu à la base
aujourd'hui où devait recevoir le plus
court aux castes et de la chaîne vous
souvenez du casse-tête à 15000 euros
baisser un petit rigolo à côté donc on
devait se faire livrer le résoudre film
et le monter et et vous le diffuser là
au moment où vous regardez cette vidéo
comme loïc et denis sont positifs au co
vite j'ai pas envie de tourner ce projet
là avec quelqu'un d'autre donc à
attendre leur retour et puis on vous
diffusera peut-être fin février ou début
mars n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
activer la cloche pour bien voir passer
la vidéo si ça vous intéresse aussi vous
savez que je finis mon ancien spectacle
de singularité que je suis en train
d'écrire le nouveau avec une tournée qui
s'appelle en création 60 villes entre
janvier et juin janvier c'est complet
février c'est qu'on peut aussi il reste
quelques vides ce sont des petites
salles c'est pour ça que c'est très vite
complet parce que c'est la phase de
démarrage où j'écris je teste de gens
avec des numéros j'en remets donc c'est
pour ça que c'est que dans les petites
salles si vous voulez venir je vous fais
la liste vite fait le lien et dans la
description que je serai à côté d'annecy
le 10 mars à côté de quimper le 18 mars
à connaître comme le 26 mars près de
paris le 1er avril à strasbourg le 14
avril à troyes le 15 avril à côté de
cannes le 27 mai à nantes le premier à
côté de tours le 2 juin à marseille le
17 juin à tous dans le 18 juin besançon
le 30 juin est encore mal au moment où
vous voyez cette vidéo les billetteries
ont ouvert pour les dernières il a sa
part genève palavas lille demain
dunkerque fourmies et lance je compte
sur vous pour venir voir ses labos
créatif c'est très cool et au moins on a
vraiment le temps de se voir à la fin
des spectacles ici jo mais deux autres
vidéos ina sur le sommeil et une sur les
rêves lucides moi je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard tu peux abonnés tout ça
tout ça tout de manière j'arrête de le
dire vous le fait ou pas c'est vous qui
voyez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao